l'heure de gloire est terminée pour le
populaire humoriste fait les bandes dans
une enquête du quotidien la presse huit
femmes témoignent contre lui elle
allègue avoir été victime d'un conduites
sexuelles de la part de l'humoriste
entre 2006 et 2015 les allégations des
présumées victimes n'ont pas été
vérifiés par radio canada il ne fait
l'objet d'aucune accusation criminelle
l'éventail des comportements qu'on lui
reproche est vaste on évoque des
commentaires déplacés des touches et non
désirées et des contacts sexuels sans
consentement
assurant ne pas vouloir commenter le cas
précis de l'humoriste le premier
ministre françois legault a néanmoins
réagi
c'est très préoccupant
moi j'ai toutes les victimes à dénoncer
sa peau de classe en 2022 dans notre
société l'humoriste a réagi aux
allégations en se disant atterré par ce
qu'il a lu ne reconnaissant pas la
personne décrite est bouleversée par la
tempête que sa femme et ses enfants
devront traverser il annonce quitté la
vie publique par respect pour ses
collaborateurs et ses employeurs dans la
déferlante de réactions celle de la
police de gatineau montré du doigt par
une présumée victime qui aurait
rencontré les policiers en 2007 sans
être prise au sérieux selon elle on
invite la personne ou les personnes qui
le veulent à se présenter chez nous et
on pourra repartir à zéro et prendre la
version de ces victimes là qui de ce
qu'on comprend au besoin de parler avec
les policiers donc on les invite
fortement à venez nous rencontrer cette
victime alléguée a justement l'intention
de porter plainte
ils demandent de porter plainte
je suis dans mon pays je ne faisais plus
eu au québec il nous fallait des congés
déjà prévu de revenir au québec et dans
trois semaines pour
confirmer le milieu de l'humour est une
nouvelle fois touché par un scandale lié
à de l'inconduite sexuelle comment
peut-on expliquer cette récurrence ya
plusieurs facteurs de vulnérabilité le 1
par exemple c'est que les rapports de
pouvoir sont très présents sont très
asymétriques
très peu de personnes qui sont salariés
les gens ont des contrats travail à
l'appui ce qui fait en sorte que ya pas
de l'employeur à qui on peut dénoncer
d'une façon on nous dit que les
dénonciations publiques anonyme c'est
pas la chose à faire mais qu'on va la
police on se fait pas croire donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait on est dans un cul de sac
en ce moment je pense qu'il faut
vraiment discuté c'est les bonnes se
retire de la vie publique et de la scène
à la radio bell média annoncés rompre
ses liens d'affaires avec l'humoriste
ici et met le mieux radio canada
montréal